before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys sign up for our
memberships to be a part of the live
chat the second half of the show we also
have
a twitch page and a facebook page that
is new the links to those are in the
description
um
and we have a new recruiter so if you
guys want to come on the show
and you have um possibly feminists that
want to come on the show dm eddie the
link is in the description
i forget anything
oh and we have the show we have
questions if you want to submit a show
topic um there is a link to that in the
description too
so today i have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and where you're from starting with jess
hi i'm jess or jessica i am from
california i'm 28 years old and my
relationship status is single
hey guys i'm samuel
um i'm 30 years old and my relationship
status is single i'm from south london
hi i'm lola i'm 28 years old my
relationship status is in a relationship
and i'm from south london as well
hi guys my name is omar i'm 26 years old
and i'm from northwest london i'm also
single
so
today's topic is talking about equality
so in 2022 my question is do you think
women want to be equal
you can start and go around
i think they want to but they don't
understand
what that comes with or what it actually
is
yeah
heavy that's where the crown in it like
they want they want the crown they don't
know how heavy it is
um i also think
that some women think that they want
equality but they don't realize what it
takes in terms of equity which we'll get
into probably um and what that means um
and if it's actually achievable in the
ground scheme of things um yeah
so impossible
equality sounds like a great idea and
that doesn't mean that it is but
what people normally want is
egalitarianism and i think it's gone
kind of the opposite way where it's not
about equality anymore it's about cherry
picking things to suit people what do
you mean by that
so
if you
if you what's the gut what kind of
territorianism
equality like you know like feminists
really started um talking about
when it first started people
that yeah people didn't have the right
to vote people you know we expected to
be barefoot and pregnant in the house
and then now
cool after first and second wave
feminism that changed
and people started wanted different
things in their life and so
now what pearl's saying is in 2022 do i
think that there are
like all of these
what is stopping women from being from
this so-called equality and i think most
people when they complain about let's
say jobs like they always talk about
ceos but they never talk about hard
manual labor jobs like cleaning out
sewers or power lines or train lines and
things like that so that's what what
what i mean by cherry picking
so you mean equality when it suits them
for their base on their lives yeah i
think so cool
so um
a recent
idea that i've had right
is um women so you mentioned that women
um didn't have the right to vote and
that was the one of the first things
that we fought for but the reason women
didn't have the right to vote was
because they didn't want to be drafted
yeah so that's true for america so in
2022 if women had to be equally drafted
to men
do you think they would still want the
right the right to vote no no absolutely
not and that's interesting because um a
while ago when the
ukraine and russia crisis begun um i
went out with eddie actually to
do like a mini documentary series and
ask people about their opinions on the
crisis and we did ask some women about
if they
how they would feel about if they had to
be drafted and a lot of them were like
oh no i wouldn't want to do that i
wouldn't want to do it and equally men
were saying no i wouldn't want to do
that so i even think what people fight
for now whether male or female or
would be different because there's a lot
of men that would say they wouldn't want
to be drafted versus women i personally
i wouldn't really want to be drafted no
but do i think equally my brother
actually my brother was in the of me
but maybe one of my male counterparts
might also not want to be but i i think
we do i actually think that women do
pick and choose when it's convenient for
them to have equality because they don't
understand
as i think jessica said what that
actually means they're just trying to
say oh
it's different there's a difference
between having equal opportunity
and it being based on what we call
equity which is the process to get to
equality so
equality is that everyone is on a level
like everyone has the same opportunity
so
if you look at it in a visual for
example say there's a window right and
i'm five foot seven and i'm with a child
who's three foot and neither of us can
reach the window we get a box and the
same size for both of us and put us both
on the box the child still can't see in
the window that's the idea of equality
right equity means that we understand
that in order for the child to see out
of the window
they need at the same height they need
to have they need to have four boxes and
i only need one therefore you're
achieving the same common goal but the
process is different because you
understand they're at a disadvantage
what would that look like
in terms of so like obviously there's
there's no boxes in society so so i'm
saying like what what in real time like
a policy what would that look like
so if you look at for example
in the workplace right the modern-day
workplace and there's a lot of talk
about diversity and inclusion and let's
take equal pay and maternity and being
parental rights in the uk now it used to
be a case where the mother the birth
mother would have get one year's
maternity leave and the the father would
usually get maybe up to a year the
father would get two weeks
which would be paternity leave now
they've said oh no we want it to be
equal so
we have shared parental leave so in
order for us to achieve some sort of
equality
the equity has been noticed that men
haven't traditionally been allowed to
decide they want to spend a year off or
nine or months off with a newborn so
they've now been given the opportunity
to make a decision about if they're
gonna split the maternity into shared
parental and maybe one of them takes six
months one takes six months so that's an
like easier example to see how it's
noted that
men were at a disadvantage therefore
they've been brought up to an equal
standard as women in terms of like
parental rights because
if you traditionally were to look at
parental rights with male and female
women
usually get
the the higher rating or the the
uh they when they win custody battles 80
of the time yeah and it's not always
correct but we don't we we for some
reason don't give men the same right
with parenting as we do with women so
i'm just i'm a little confused because
when you were talking about the box
analogy it seemed like you were
advocating that certain policies should
help certain groups more than others was
that not what you were saying no what it
does is recognize that some groups are
already at disadvantage so it creates a
fairness in the playing field to achieve
the same common goal
but how do you quantify that so like
because this is i know the visual that
you're talking about it's a very good
visual to like describe equality versus
equity like like you say if you give
people of varying heights the same
height of box it's still going to be any
unequal right but then with equity if
you try and match it so that everybody's
the same height you give people
proportionately but how do you decide
okay this person is three foot they
deserve a box that's how
i think where the lines are getting
blurred is that example is when you have
a common goal would you mean that
in in terms of sometimes the goal isn't
i mean in terms of male and female
equality the goal isn't always the same
so so if
her example is if you both have the same
goal
you try to find a way to even things out
where you both achieve the same goal but
if you don't have the same goal
do you know what i'm saying isn't that
kind of socialism though
like trying to make everyone equal
or get the point of like what they say
fairness which everyone's idea of what
is fair is yeah so it's what's a great
area isn't it yeah because when i when
it's hard because i know what you were
talking about the paternity leave but
when i've seen that visual but usually
like they're advocating for policies
that redistribute wealth a lot of the
time
in the name of equality is is that
similar to what you're saying
i wasn't really relating it to wealth
but i see what you're saying yeah like
it's more like just seeing a level
playing field where we see that certain
groups have been disadvantaged therefore
the way they need to be treated in order
to gain yeah
because to me it's like how could you
say a whole group has been disadvantaged
like it's it's people are individuals i
think i think it's going to be difficult
without defining what we're talking
about yeah because we haven't actually
defined what equality between
i think if you so an example that
i guess you can say is in the workplace
when people say that there is a um
a pay wage gap um a man might
have a
xyz to get him to become a ceo but a
woman
may have the same the same things but
there's going to be something that she's
missing
that isn't going to equate her to be a
ceo and so in that sense trying to
connect it to the box scenario
the end goal is to be ceo but the man is
going to be able to achieve it quicker
because there's just innate thing in men
that
give them that edge to be able to be a
ceo i'm not saying women can't but it's
just
he's going to get paid more because of
xyz that a woman doesn't have so
sorry
on that point um
do you also think that's because maybe
women don't push themselves to
those things so when we look at like
salary pay gap for example for myself
personally if i want to achieve a
certain salary i go in and ask for that
salary and if they don't give me that
salary i go thanks very much for the
opportunity and i bother yeah whereas
men
some women's ability to do that is not
necessarily there so they will get
offered less and accept less but
sometimes they base it on other things
for example obviously this isn't about
corporate world but if it's on pay it
might be that they're going oh well i
need more flexibility because i need to
pick up the kids or whereas a man may
not
have that in the forefront so maybe
that's why they're getting paid less so
even though
i understand completely what you're
saying even though it may not be about
like the topic may not be about wages
that's always the
first argument you hear people say when
they
want equality women want equality is a
pay gap and they don't understand like
you were saying
there are some women that will walk up
to a boss and be like i deserve this pay
this is my resume this is what i offer i
deserve this pay and then they'll get it
but most women it's just innateness not
to
step out and have that i guess you can
say like edge or just that forefront to
be like i deserve this give it to me or
like pay me what i'm worth a man will do
that and that's what
sets them apart from us and gives them
that one-up to be able to run a full
company like if they need to go into a
business meeting lay it out say this is
what we need if you are not able to give
it to us we're gonna go to the next one
a woman might negotiate yeah but like to
me i feel like it's fair as long as the
opportunity is there mm-hmm like i don't
think women should get special treatment
in any way just a matter of perception
really because
again all right let's go back to this
fence analogy or window whatever you
want to call it it's like
talking about perception is that if you
view yourself as disenfranchised and
like
a victim
and then
like ah i'm three foot tall but actually
you're five foot five
and then you look at someone who might
be six foot and you're looking at me
like you bastard you're so tall and then
there's envy there you see what i mean
and then you're going but i deserve a
bigger box i need to stop right yeah
yeah yeah this is what i'm trying to say
is that
sometimes i'm not saying that like i've
worked in a couple workplaces where i
see like i'll be the only guy yeah and
then the manager's mail and then if i've
got to be in my bonnet about something i
can't let it go and i'll be like i've
got a bone to pick with you and i would
have to talk to my manager about it i've
noticed that with my female colleagues
they won't say anything they'll be like
no that keeps them yeah similarly with
with with pay rises if i feel that i'm
deserving of a pay rise
i'm gonna walk up to the manager like
i'll be like listen i deserve more money
and if he tells me no i'm gone no
negotiating i think is not natural to
women at all it's really hard for me i
have a really hard time with it like
genuinely in business but like honestly
i think being a woman has been an
advantage for me at work in every job
i've had ever because most especially if
you're a young woman most guys are
attracted to you yeah and people tend to
pay you more attention if they're
attracted to you what about when your
boss is a female and they're not
attracted to you and they're into life
yeah i think pretty privileged is void
there i do i don't i don't even i think
women like are more perceptive to like
helping other women too there's like the
like the sister code type deal like
honestly i think being a woman in the
workplace is an advantage and i was
actually going to bring up a study so
have you guys heard about the study
google did
no so basically people were complaining
that men um there that men made more
money at google and so google finds it's
underpaying many men as it addresses
wage equality
when google conducted a study recently
to determine whether the company was
underpaying women and members of
minority groups it found to the surprise
of just about everyone that men were
paid less money for than women for doing
similar work this study was which
disproportionately led to pay raises for
thousands of men is done every year but
the latest findings arrived as google
and other companies in silicon valley
is
is increasing pressure to deal with the
wage gender issues in the workplace from
sexual harassment to wage discrimination
gender equality inequality is a
radioactive topic at google the labor
department is investigating whether the
company systematically underpaid women
it has been sued by former employees who
claim they were paid less than men with
the same qualification and last fall
thousands of google employees were
protested the way the company handles
sexual harassment claims against top
executives
and
critics said that the results of the pay
study could give a false impression
company officials acknowledge that it
did not address whether women were hired
at a lower pay grade than men with
similar qualifications
um
google seems but to be advocating a
flawed and incomplete sense of equality
by making sure men and women receive
similar salaries for similar work said
joel emerson chief executive of per
increasing
a consulting company that advises
companies on strategies for increasing
diversity so basically they did this
whole study and they find out that up
backwards yeah that is the opposite
and i found another one that says um
basically
i'm trying to find the other one but
basically they look in like major cities
of women under a certain age and they
out they make more money than men
that's interesting and so it's like well
why do we always hear about this wage
gap because it's been talked about for
so many years that they don't want to do
the research themselves to
find out if it's actually true that they
just keep i'm saying pay gap pay get
paid
i actually i work in human resources so
i've seen this data for for both um
gender and also for race as well and
what we find is that it's because
sometimes women or those of different um
ethnicities actually are applying for
lower paid roles so they're in the more
administrative roles so they're trying
to say we're getting paid less than men
but if you're coming in as an
administrator and not as a sales manager
regardless of if that administrator was
male or female they're in a lower paid
role but it's because less men are
applying for those maybe administrative
or entry-level roles so really it's less
about
they're getting paid less and more about
the position yeah the positions that
they're applying for their force
and 60 of women have never asked for a
raise so it's like how are we going to
complain about not getting paid less or
about getting paid less if we don't even
ask for more money and they they say
they quit
before they ask for more money and it's
like and we're going to whine and we're
not getting paid enough what they got it
the wrong way around you should ask
first and then if you don't get it on
and then leave because it's then like
okay i've asked you for something you
don't give it to me so now you're
talking about sales it's like i'm not
worth what i say i'm worth yeah do you
see what i mean so it's this bad
branding it's like okay no cool i gotta
go i'm sure i'll find somebody that will
pay me that i wanna have i think it's
similar to like you know like how women
don't like to shoot their own shot
and how like they'll have a whole
conversation in their head they're like
if i stare at his picture long enough oh
manifest manifest yes it's like right
down to my journal if i yeah if i
put it right i feel like i'll get a
raise maybe he would sense that i need a
raise
i have a question to to mix up a bit
when we're talking about females wanting
equality if you look at like
relationships with men and women right
so
traditionally we've spoken before about
um
the amount the gender roles of male and
female and men not traditionally perhaps
wanting to date higher earning women
than them because traditionally they are
wanting to be providers and they're not
wanting to have
a partner who has that more masculine
energy or that maybe earns more than
them because it's in some way could
possibly hurt the male ego so if we're
talking about female equality
is that really what women want so if you
are
the same as your man for example so say
for example you you and the same as your
man right
and
but you still expect him to pay for the
dinners pay for the holiday look after
the finances at home therefore you don't
want equality then do you you want you
want some sense of privilege that you're
allowed to have the freedom to go do
what you want to do
but then you don't you then you then
admit that equality because you're like
oh no he should be dealing with that
then that's not well it's like we want
we want traditional benefits but we're
not traditional women i mean how many
how many how many brides are virgins
and you and you are yes
yeah that's that's what i'm saying
because it's like modern women don't
have any of the things that men want and
they're demanding
um traditional oh man they want their
cake and eat it yeah yeah they they want
to be courted like women used to be but
they're not virgins like women used to
be right and they want guys to make more
money and take care of all the bills but
they're not they don't they don't cook
they don't clean that has the man chain
has have a man involved like what's the
deal i mean i think i think men are more
feminine because in
i just think
as women's standards get higher and
higher and higher there's like a larger
and larger group of men without purpose
because like men because men
need women to like motivate them to do
things i think also it's probably not as
feasible
like now financially like before with
like um
[Music]
um disposable income etc like you as a
man it was
it was more feasible to
have a job and cover everything and now
that you know especially in the big
cities we're living in is
is this is well i think a lot of women
don't want to give up the lifestyle
mm-hmm so it's like all right so
i was having this conversation with
someone the other day when they're
talking about like you need a certain
amount of money to have like a bunch of
kids
but um like a lot of people aren't
willing to give up like eating out yeah
like they want to live in the big city
instead of moving to the country where
it's more affordable everyone gets a car
like there's a lot a standard of living
that women aren't willing to give up
yeah so my gripe with
like money when it comes to this whole
situation is
okay let's say if i was in a room with a
feminist that would look me in the eye
and be like there's a gender pay gap but
in the same ref she's like to me i
expect you to pay for everything
do i not deserve more money than you
then that's what i would ask her like if
that is genuinely if you want that role
and i it's expected of me socially that
i should be paying for everything then
why don't i get more money but you want
to have the same amount as me
or maybe more
and you want to get paid you want me to
take care of it and i haven't got
something i'm not sure if women like
everyone's got tests in it you test
people in different ways
so
my thing is
i give a girl three times
to have the um i give her the
opportunity three times to
say ah let me get that or do you want to
go home if she doesn't do that three
times we'll talk
if she doesn't do that yeah it's a no
for me or do you mean like
you go out on a first date or whatever
and she doesn't offer to buy around no
it's not even that because if i asked
you out i asked you out do you know oh
so if she asks you out and then it's not
even like that look let's see okay let's
say
you've met up a couple of times yeah the
date the date thing's out of the picture
and just like
you're just meeting up
i mean three might be extreme but
if you're meeting up regularly in a row
free's not a lot just
do you ever ask them to pay
not but this is what i'm saying i have
female friends yeah that
like they will barge me out the way when
they're like no no no you got like stop
it you're being silly now and i for me
that's attractive so it's not
it's not traditional
but
it's like okay but do you ask them to
pay do you ever ask them to pay
because this is this is this is my thing
with it is that
it's not that i don't i mind paying it's
the gesture yeah that's what i was gonna
say it's about it's about because i've
heard from a lot of guys it's like the
entitlement where the girl it's not even
necessarily that guys like don't want to
pay it's that the entitlement they're
expected to pay preach um and and the
data backs this up because a third of
women
um admit to only dating men because of
the free food
there's women because there's women who
will
have dudes in their phone and i've said
it on the show before i've had friends
have dudes on their phone and say free
mail calm steak daddy said yo just hit
him up whoops
yeah
yeah yeah and that's cool yeah oh yeah
from the end
i have never gone on a date with a guy
for free food because i'm like i could
be doing something
else how cheap are you yeah sometimes
i'll see but i think i think these girls
are getting like nice ass dinners like i
think
i'm not oh i'm not justifying it i'm
just saying like i think that's their
thought process is they can go out to
these super expensive dinners
is that the meaning
two guides like
when a woman offers to pay because some
dudes would be like how dare you
something like that yeah yeah juno is
yeah oh well i'll say for me it's like i
like the gesture that
you you enjoy my time that much you
enjoy spending time with me where is
that it's because it's a thing where if
it's convenient you may spend time with
me out of convenience like you know what
you're on at your own expense i'll spend
time with you
why do you think we always talk about
women um being used for their bodies but
we never talk about men being used for
their wallets i talk about that but
generally people well generally in the
media like the mainstream
yeah i just think that the way that
modern day society has kind of
set things up is very misconstrued i
think the modern day woman if i'm
totally honest is done out here like i i
actually feel like there's a lot of
women out there right now that i'm like
this is not making sense you're not cut
out to be someone's wife or anything
you're just a fun time and there are a
lot of women that do use men for either
their you know for monetary purposes but
i think that it's just that
traditionally because women have been
seen to be at disadvantaged they
victimize themselves therefore that's
the narrative we're just going to
continue to run with yeah when it's not
necessary you think in a way we're all
modern women because none of us are
married with kids
possibly i'm i don't live within i don't
when i think of traditional i think of
someone that gets married young and has
kids what would be your definition of a
modern woman
modern woman um feminist
i think okay i think partially when i
think of modern women i think of like
feminists and like the the progressive
mindset right but
yeah but i also think like in a way
everybody's a modern woman because
no one's a virgin anymore
so you're basically okay like i'm saying
like the traditional i mean speaking for
yourself
[Laughter]
what you've been doing the last 10 years
i've been studying for the last 10
years degrees
but you know what i mean though like i
feel like in a way everyone is modern
unless you get married young and have
kids
i think like
this is also another sticky one but like
post sexual liberation sexual revolution
that's a lot of people are like they're
mad upset about it but i personally
think yeah
what dead society would we live in
everyone would have like 11 kids gay
people would have no rights [ __ ] i
just go go you know
families would probably be more together
because because after the if you look at
the chart for one birth control like the
number of women on birth control with
the divorce rate they're like they're
very similar so
this is i think the pill the invention
of the pill yes has been hijacked
completely if you actually look at the
history of it you know this is another
gripe of mine when i used a social
sciences study a student yeah so i'd be
like dominated by women i'd be in a a
seminar and i'd be like if it was a
man's problem it would be solved already
and be like
cool i don't believe you know
there's millions of men problems male
problems that still exist but so
essentially it was an endocrinologist a
male endocrinologist who was asked by a
woman
to help
create a drug with family planning right
so it was actually initially meant so at
her request he then eventually came up
with the pill as we know it today so but
it was actually meant for family people
that didn't want to have 11 kids one of
the main people who pushed it was
margaret sanger a eugenicist
and they pushed it into yeah they they
pushed it into minority communities
yes but again it's population control
yeah yeah that's like i'm saying so but
then you do eugenics i mean like
yeah
okay
same thing's been done with an abortion
in the feminist movement you know i mean
yeah it was it was both it was like a um
but i'm saying i don't really think they
were it was conducive to families when
they're pushing eugenics into minority
community you know i think he was saying
like the start of it like the idea of
the pill was supposed to be this way but
then
[Music]
when it started out it wasn't like this
massive conspiracy just to like control
people's i i do i do actually think it
was at the request of women that were
like yo like i don't want to have it
like a million kids and then it's just
kind of got look nowadays you give
contraceptive pills to 15 year olds oh
yeah do you know what i mean i don't
want acne i don't want period pains it's
a hormonal thing that's that's because
it's used for yes right for other things
and so
and again we have normalized that so
like if we're giving that to to kids
when they're 15 let's be honest and then
we're not art it's a contraceptive pill
yeah but you can say that the road to
hell is paved with good intentions isn't
it yeah my head up i hit up
so
so it's like you're just taking away the
consequence and that's that's really
what birth control does is it takes away
the consequence from women
because before they had before they had
to be selective with who they slept with
and so
involuntary conception wasn't it's only
been
has been a thing for so long and only
recently it's not a thing right
in valentine's day i don't know that
quote actually so yeah it's like
involuntary so back in the day or even
in societies out there now i don't have
birth control like you say you have to
you wouldn't just sleep with anytime
they can harry you met well you were
going to have you you knew that the
consequence of that is
his children yeah and i i what i'm
saying is with the pill i was like cool
like i said i think it's been hijacked i
think if you let's be honest
not everyone in this room has had sex
just for procreative purposes like
there's times when you're like cool i
just want to have sex and that's fine
especially there's times yeah do you
know what i'm trying to say so that's
not the definition yeah speak for
yourself
the default pleasure yeah right so there
we go he says you know on occasions when
you want pleasure over procreating so
but my point is the way that this is
being that's a good point but
we're talking about is as if we're just
having sex for children and obviously
we're not so if you're in a like a
long-standing committed relationship
whether that is in a marriage or not
then i think but i'm saying people like
figured that out sooner before so like
they didn't want to get pregnant there
was like shotgun weddings so
so even if they did they still like did
you know the quote-unquote right thing
yeah
and so it's like birth control took away
the consequence so then women can sleep
with whoever they want and have no
consequence for it i mean it's crazy
like the way you're throwing the word
consequence like it's like but it's true
as a woman because
i'm not saying i disagree because when
you think about it like before before
women had to prioritize that like that a
man would stick around yep where like
now girls can prioritize who they're
attracted to and that's why you see a
smaller and smaller percentage of men
sleeping with all the girls and maybe
they'll get a kid off of him and then
marry the other guy it's a mating
strategy yeah
i mean
now like we're talking again reference
to that involuntary contracep uh
conception thing right
women are now in a position where they
can choose not to have a kid so
like
they've kind of i'm not like a guy can
have sex with a woman and like at least
i don't know coitus interrupted so
whatever kind of shoddy way that you
don't want to have a kid and they they
don't really have to do with the
repercussions like that but now like
you'll say it's like
i i feel when i talk when we talk what's
a modern woman
they get really offended when you when
when you try and explain to them that
sleeping around for a man and a woman is
not the same thing
it really helps i always i always ask
the question what's one double standard
that doesn't benefit women outside of
body count
can't say body count
that doesn't benefit or that yeah that
doesn't benefit yeah that doesn't
benefit women so like when we get there
we get the free dates
we get quotas at work like what
anyone name one
which i'm wrecking my brain it doesn't
benefit women there ain't none
simple answer right
i mean society is getting a century with
that said though question do you then
think that um women are almost uh
the orchestras of their own destruction
in this current class yes
yeah
well it's like i think the short term it
benefits us in the short term but then
long term it doesn't yeah it's strange
she says why do women seem to think that
in the short term that that's going to
last long obviously we've had this
conversation before and
a lot of women are quite idealistic
they're not really
they don't think it will last long
because they're not thinking about no
you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised that that's that's
sometimes that women aren't
disillusioned that's the right
i think if you leave women to their own
devices then they'll just cause the
structure
they think
return our rights don't return our
rights
leave a credit card with them that's an
example if if you look at society and
really deep it with the more freedoms
that women have had
the more
degradation societies suffered as a
consequence can i ask a question about
that then eddie always
so with that being said do you also
think that's because
because we haven't had the same rights
we're still finding our feet and
learning how to deal with that so if you
look at like you know like generational
curses and you you can relate it to
other things so like i don't just think
about women's rights or any you might
look at race or social economic status
if you for example
you're from um you're from like the hood
or whatever and then suddenly you get a
load of money you may become hood rich
and not know how to invest that and make
it long-term because tradition because
you haven't had that before so you're
still learning how to cope with that
level of power or newfound freedom so is
that why you do not think that
consciousness
it's because we're built out of every
bad decision we make like there's no
consequence for women we sleep around
what happens we have birth control we we
get pregnant what happens abortion bails
us out we get we get married and then
get divorced by the guy we can get
alimony and child support
yeah because we don't want equality
that's what i'm saying like we can't
it's it's like
how are we supposed to learn if like
there's no consequence
i think i think like so i think this
there's a direct comparison to something
like slavery yeah you can say that ah
since the abolition of slavery you know
people um
black people can do what they need to do
at working etc etc
we have gone so far
in society that most women born today
don't suffer the
the things that women went through
previous times that's completely gone to
the point where women are now more
powerful than men in most situations so
to make the the
the
the rationale that you know that that
that is still young in the in the
women's psyche and that's why they
behave that way i think would be
irrelevant because you've had enough
time most women born today have never
suffered those things and you've had it
good like really good better than men
i think the repair and fema's
accountability that you know men when we
are in our rooms when we have the safety
of
not having i'm saying we speak about the
lack of accountability of women and i
think it stems from what you are saying
about women just constantly not being
held at accountability it's never their
fault though yeah and even even if women
like if they if they become homeless
what happens too
shows shelters yeah there's we're always
bailed out
granted like i think there's a lot of
sent men that bail them out
see all marrying these single moms these
baby mamas and that's another way like
they can still get remarried and guys
can't even say i don't date fat chicks
and i don't date single mothers i can't
say that
and they're bailed out of that bad
decision too because then their men are
shamed into liking them mm-hmm
i think someone was saying that um
is a as a result of men trying to defend
their mothers like subconsciously so
like men will be grown up in
single-parent homes and they will see
their mother's behaving assertive away
and then see other women behave that way
as well and because that woman slightly
impersonates his mom subconsciously he
defends those actions not understanding
that defending these actions is what's
creating that the negative aspects of
society
about men though so in my opinion with
that if you look at for example uh a lot
of women do that with their sons and
that's something that i've noticed if
i've dated a guy who's who's from a
single parent household and he's he's
not treating me right or whatever i can
look at the fact that their dad did
similar things and but their mum is not
holding them account and saying like you
shouldn't be treating your partner like
that whether they're because it's their
son it's fine so we're still going
around the same cycle regardless of
which side you're on the surface level
um
men are also raised to protect women
yeah for women so just instinctively
like you you can see it with like male
and female friendships where even though
that's his friend and he's not trying to
have sex with her he'll still sometimes
pay for is he not
just his ego as a man he may pay even
though i'm saying just yeah yeah big
facts
do you think that's the same for
all men regardless of how they are
raised whether they're raised by a
single mom or a single dad or both
parents it's not it's society it's not
it's not the parents it's like
yeah i think the environment so i think
everything starts in the home right so
what you may have seen
if you look traditionally like people
have grown up in a two-parent household
versus those who have had single parent
households
they will their outcomes in life their
journeys will be different because
of the environment because you were
talking about how men are protected when
people be providers i was asking is that
like conducive for all men's based on if
they were raised in a
single parent with a mom or a just their
dad or raised i think it's biology
because like historically men had to
protect women
that's how it's always that's how it's
always been you can't undo our dna i
mean you see it in shows you hear it in
music it's kind of it's kind of like
okay if
if a girl hits a guy and he hits back
there's still a part of us that's like
oh why'd you do that even though even
though i promote equal rights equal
lefts on this channel if she hits you
you can hit back i agree but but there's
still a part of like guys and girls i
think that are like oh maybe you
shouldn't because there's instinct as
you said yeah
where if two guys if one guy hits the
other and then he hits back everyone's
like yeah you deserve that
and i think this goes back to the this
this idea of the modern man of the
modern woman because if you strip away
civilization in terms of that technology
we revert back to our tribal state so
that the more if you go to third world
countries there's no talk of masculinity
and feminine knows his role the woman
knows her role it's only in these in the
first world country where you know
feminism and the feminine nazis and
whatnot have uh the gynocentric order
and
their power have started to take away
that you see the difference in between
how men and women are supposed to behave
gender roles isn't as quintessential in
in our space than there's so that's go
on
as in like
you know the the convenience of like
modern technology and and the way we
live
means that what is required from the
woman and the man isn't the same it's
not basically back home like yeah
but that's why we're still having these
conversations because
as women make more money and become
equal to men in certain standards
there's still certain things that demand
of those men which is what the
traditional women back in the third
world countries expect of their men so
in this in this in this context women
still have the same expectations of a
third world country or people who are
still more tribal and the way they
behave so i have a question for the guys
if you were dating a girl and she made a
significantly more money than you would
you ever consider staying home
what that's one of my goals
that goes against what you said earlier
about a man being a provider and uh
wanting to take care of the dick what
are you talking about oh my days
what are you talking about
so wait wait so home girl comes home and
says why aren't the dishes washed we're
going to shang won't say that why not
laying it down cause you already watched
this let it stop also you're just living
in a store let me let me just let me
just get this straight i'm
your plan let me i just want to
understand you can correct me yeah is to
basically dickmatize a girl so you can
just no no i'm being silly no no no i'm
in silly way i've been i've been sitting
busy wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i'm
being silly homeless wait wait i'm being
and for me
like if i can provide
in
every other area like what my like
looking after the kids she didn't say
dad though sorry did you specify parent
or did you say stay at home so were you
staying at home this was the question
because she didn't specify so do you
mean i'm assuming they have kids yeah
okay sorry what would you stay at home
for if you made it sound like you were
just staying at home just for the fun no
no no no no no no no no okay so if she
only knows
where your job is
how could you still be the head of the
household how would that work we're in
the apron
no what do you mean no i'm just curious
like how would that work to you
being in your head because some this
this happens so do you think women can
submit to a guy even if she's the one
that's making the money yeah
okay how
what do you mean how
how is she gonna submit to you when
you're yeah you're bummed
by a woman that isn't driven but where
her core values isn't money so it's seen
is understood as a resource yeah i'm
saying because you you see some
relationships where women are leading
the relationship and they are not the
breadwinner
where who
well i think the situations i've seen
where like women make more money than
the guy like she still comes home and
submits but typically he's not a
stay-at-home dad
okay
that i've seen i don't know like maybe
you guys have met others
i got the source to be a stay-at-home
dad
i can't speak for the other that might
be you being idealistic i don't know how
long-term that is because and i'll say
this we had a guest on our podcast
can i say something
i i am you know what you guys there is a
variable that i'm ignoring which is that
i don't have money but because like
um i like i work from home i have like
e-commerce businesses i've run and i
have money i i
still have money in my head in that
scenario but no but
yeah and if you guys are talking about
you you don't i don't have no
no no no no i'm changing my answer if i
wasn't me but that's not me so no no no
it's redundant
because i literally we had a guest on on
the domino podcast and he he started off
being a stay-at-home dad
and we just wanted to understand his
journey as a stay-at-home dad yeah and
he just said he got hella toxic because
he started to embody a lot of the
feminine um principles that a woman
would follow so he took on the
characteristics of a woman so when she'd
worked late he'd be like where is she
yeah pulling the phone
jumping in these cars go find her
where she he said he turned into the
woman and and he made him feel
disgusting just because he had no source
of income and he was a state but what
you just said is key right yeah that's
exactly i was but with my answer it was
going to be like yo if i've got i've
married i'm probably like if i have kids
with some or not that for me is they
might not be married but we're together
you know what i mean so cool i've made
that decision with someone
so now there's we're talking about like
gender roles early about cool there's
roles that are being dished out if i do
i have
does
would my male ego
prevent me from taking care of my kid no
absolutely not of course but
the fact of the matter is staying at
home
not earning money yeah whether you're
male or female i don't care in my
opinion it's never a good look so that
doesn't mean i think okay no one should
be everyone should be you a career woman
you should you know i'm saying there
should be some way that you were earning
your own that's the thing if she
understands
that's
i hear the thing
hear that but i think for a woman
herself
like my point is then she's dependent on
you do you get it and now that's just
not good for any well bro
things are done correctly sorry no no i
was just gonna say i've heard
i've heard dude and it's like
mind-blowing i was watching a video with
um
iman uh how do you say his last name
basketball player
he was he was like screaming in the
camera like
we don't care how much a woman makes a
man that has money doesn't care if a
woman
has money or not he's gonna take care
because that's innate man i'm like
i'm gonna have my coin but they're like
they don't care women provide value in
other ways so then and this is why it
gets broken up into roles so men will
take care of the roles where it becomes
the leadership the breadwinning making
sure that the woman's secure and safe to
do the jobs necessary to take care of
the kids at home that's your role my
role is to make sure that everybody's
safe and protected so we both play our
roles and the things work
you're going back to properly
do you think eddie do you think there's
any way that a girl can submit if she's
the breadwinner
and you wish you cancer yeah
if she's the breadwinner yeah i didn't
ask you
i don't
no i don't i don't see how she could
submit she's the breadwinner mm-hmm like
what because
i would support her if she came home and
they said my man's this food not ready
on the table i'd be like he needs to
because someone's got to be the weapon
yeah yeah
yeah she's the husband for taking off
the leadership role so
i don't see how she would submit and if
she did i don't think it would last long
because at some point she's gonna wake
up and be like something here is not
right it wouldn't be fully can i ask you
a question so what about in the
scenarios where
you're but well both working modern days
one of my ex right who i was with for
about seven years
one of the reasons we
got to separate him was because i didn't
feel like he was really pulling his
weight and i'd overtaken him in life
right we discussed this briefly before
i'd overtaken him in leaps and bounds
and he was starting to just
be bummy and i was like this is not
making sense so however however however
however i also have
quite masculine energy in terms of the
fact that i want my independence i will
work i like to earn my own money et
cetera so i would not
yes but not with all the
madnesses right so for me it was like
well
i would like some sort of
equilibrium it doesn't have to be
completely
all equality but i was co-dependency in
a in a sense
where we're both working towards
doing
some roles do you see what i mean but
equally i would never
let a man run all the finances or
anything like i don't i don't want that
so what what would you if you're
working more than he is or making more
money what would you expect from him
i would then expect him to contribute in
other ways so for example so would you
expect him to like cook clean
yeah possibly but it doesn't mean ice
dropped that though so that for me it
was but someone's got to do it like the
majority of you know it's making more
and it's making all so i'm like that's
why i'm getting a bit confused so
when when you're saying making more
i'm like a woman that makes more can
submit
but it is the dynamics of the difference
and what you guys are talking about is a
woman that makes all of it but i'm
talking about a woman that makes it
significant
i don't i don't think a woman can fully
submit if even if she makes
significantly a little bit i don't think
a woman can fully submit because there's
going to be something innate and her
that says i i earn more than you when
you should be earning more than me no
as a guy that has sex with women no no i
think i think girls i think girls can
but she has to see the guys better than
her at something
and so that's what i mean like it
doesn't necessarily in my opinion have
to be financial it could be like that
maybe that's what i'm saying like fully
yeah but i'm saying
no i think i think there's girls that do
it it's just not the norm especially
with modern women a lot of women don't
want to be with men that make less than
them anyway
what a lot of women don't want to be
with men that make them less so that's
true
50 of women at 30 are single and
childless do they want equality then
therefore do they want equality no yeah
yes i do want equality
i think people
don't think about this deeply enough
there's an element of
that evolutionary psychology as well as
um biology involved in this conversation
so when we're talking about finances and
whether a woman would submit
it's not necessarily literally the money
aspect that's the important part it's
the fact that she doesn't feel safe in
life
in your hands how can i fully submit if
you haven't ticked all the boxes and
that's where the hypergamy thing comes
in so even if women carry masculine
traits hypergamy doesn't go nowhere she
still needs to feel secure on the
situation otherwise she's going to need
to take that step and either take that
role on or find someone who better who
can so you might just be the guy that's
there for the time being and then she'll
find someone better that's why monkey
does at the beginning of it women are
always going with the trappers and the
bad boys and as they get older they end
up with the accountants and the
businessmen but why do men do it the
other way around when sometimes they
start with the
the more secure females when they're
younger or similar age and then when
they get older
but when they get older then they go for
the younger females who are therefore
not actually the right material they're
less damaged
and and but also less capable
technically they're going for the same
girl they just didn't go up in age right
because if they're 23 and she's 23 and
they're 43 and she's 23. they've gone
for the same goal
the younger the girl is the less trauma
he has to deal with
and like that's what men value purity
and youth and so he's just going for the
best that he can get like the guy wants
the youngest hottest tightest thing he
can get like all the women are peaceful
more time you've been through too much
and why why should i take on all that
baggage yeah back lady
it's the journey of regression fact and
regression i'm saying actually you don't
have noticed with guys i i've noticed
that
when they're younger
if guys can right cause not all guys get
laid but like
they'll they'll date the like super
attractive like bad chicks and kind of
the same way like girls will date the
bad boys like they'll do it with like
the ig models like that sort of thing
like the nines and tens and they'll
realize like they're more trouble than
they're worth like i've heard this story
a couple times in red pill would you say
that's
it true what people are doing for me i'm
too i'm too cognizant to do that kind of
stuff so like i wouldn't ever i value
peace over anything so for me if i see a
girl who lacks self-awareness i'm not
interested because i know your energy is
going to affect mine it's going to
inhibit my ability to do certain things
that i'm trying to do to grow in my life
so i'll avoid those things but if it's a
quick chop i will just
said a good job define self-awareness
though self-awareness in the sense of
you like understanding yourself so
understanding that
who are you now and where you're trying
to be how does the negative aspects of
you who you are affect the things around
you and what are you doing currently to
change those things i think a
consequence of a lot of relationships
falling apart is people lacking
self-awareness because they don't
understand the problems within and they
expect other people to fix the problems
that they think they have when that when
you're supposed to work on the problem
and then
you match someone who's growing as well
and then used to grow together but what
often happens is that you get one person
who thinks they're the end of one be you
and one person who's growing so you get
a fixed mentality and and the
personality that's growing you're
actually gonna grow each other so what i
find in a lot of women that i talk to is
that they lack their self awareness so
they think i'm pretty i'm gonna i'm
gonna have this rest of my life and you
didn't just stop growing i'm still doing
my thing so naturally you're gonna find
better but you were talking about
hypergamy earlier yeah so
i when pearl was talking about how like
i don't know i can't remember how you
verbalized it articulated but you were
saying that women get like a a hand up i
guess a step up in life right yeah
pretty well yeah pretty privileged yeah
right but so like with hypergamy i feel
a lot of time they're just coasting you
know i mean like you can just snatch
you can just like i've seen um
what is that some satchel baron cohen
film where he's like taking the piss out
of
the meat it's not real it's like a spoof
and then it's like a baby sugar baby
course and she's like like what what you
after and with a dead straight face like
oh like i'm looking someone that's like
close to death and then she was just
like oh yeah like you should look for a
heart patient then like but real talk
shut up yeah it's in the sacha brown
cohen film yeah and it's like a skit
where exactly as i described she's like
going to like kind of like how you went
to the pickup course in your life cool
he was going to a sugar baby course
and
the character was like i want someone on
the verge of death and she was like oh
yeah go for someone with like a heart
patient i was like yo
that's another thing that's just not
talked about in our flat because we talk
about how men use power to get sex but
we don't talk about how women use sex to
get power yeah
or even okay
when i when that stuff came out like the
me too stuff a couple years ago and they
were talking about how girls were like
sleeping with directors for roles
but they they painted the girls as
victims but i'm like why'd you do
it to the next story i'm like why'd you
i would i wouldn't do that for a role so
why why'd you do it why didn't you blow
the whistle then yeah but then everyone
everyone everyone painted them as like
victims but i'm like no you're just a
hoe it's weird how feminism does that
because in certain situations girls are
naive and they just
need to be looked after well they're not
naive they just don't want to take
accountability
like that like if you're going to
remember we say women are the
gatekeepers of sex so unless a guy
forces himself on you of course you
allow him to come in yeah so in a
situation where you're trying to acquire
a role
he can only do so much you have to
accept him coming inside you so then how
does it turn from
the woman who is the gatekeeper of sex
she is now the victim
in certain situations if they play off
that she's naive and he used his power
to seduce her and this that another i
mean powell was definitely a wrong it's
like a guy saying she used her beauty to
seduce me
[Music]
but it's like i don't know i just think
we always are taking accountability off
of women and even in that situation like
you're not a victim if you got to be a
award-winning hollywood actress because
you slept with some dudes that was the
price you paid is what you yeah yeah and
now you're gonna cry about it like why
didn't you do that before you got the
role some people see it as a
vulnerability but i get what you're
saying but i'm saying i think it's the
regret you know like now you've got it
is like oh [ __ ]
i don't even think it's vulnerability
it's people that want to cheat and take
shortcuts and they do it yeah what age
do you think a woman is cognizant enough
to take ownership of her sexual
behaviors and the reason i asked this
because i was watching um i remember
what the the podcast was but this lady
was 12 yeah and she said
i would sleep with guys to make money
because it was fun they would buy me
alcohol and i'd sleep with them for
alcohol right but she said and then the
guy's like oh they used you and she goes
no i knew exactly what i was doing i
wanted to do those things and they're
still telling her no like you was a kid
you don't understand it
i don't think there's a i don't think
there's like an age because you can have
older women that still don't hold
accountability for their sexual actions
i think it's
down to the person if they want to hold
accountability for themselves and their
actions are not they can be as young as
12 or as old as 80 and still be saying
oh he took advantage of me this young 23
year old pinned me down and took
advantage of me and if they don't take
accountability for what they do
they could die never taken account i'm
just a big believer and literally your
relationships are your own fault
like i literally think that whatever
happens to you in relationships outside
of grape don't guys don't go there in
the chat like like that is literally
your own fault like if you date toxic
men that's your own fault if you like
and i like honestly every relationship
i've been in like i've been in a place
where i've been cheated on before but i
feel like it was my own fault because i
picked him so how am i gonna cry when i
picked him so does that mean then you're
not allowing yourself any grace to say
that you that certain situations develop
and when you reflect on it don't you
think okay well look at how you got to
that space where was your head space at
the time yeah i'll just be like because
like as women we know
like i just feel like
when i looked back i was like you know
what there's red flags i chose to ignore
that's my own fault and then you just
move on and then you just say okay i'm
going to end that and then move on to
the next thing
with red flags and retrospect because
there are some things that in retrospect
is a red flag but in the moment you know
there's so many things that girls talk
about what the guys are doing is like
come on you know no no no i wait i'm
with you but now now you're using
situations where it's clearly red flag
but i'm saying there are some things in
retrospect
um so it it could be like um maybe maybe
how a guy um
i i don't have a good one right now but
maybe him i don't think this is an
example yeah
a girl will see a guy using a snapchat
yeah talking to hella gal gallon
snatcher why are you talking that's a
clear red flag though that's what
again to them it's not a red flag until
they start looking in hindsight like oh
my god i probably should have you know
saying that to me
that's what i'm saying there's so many
things that women nowadays say are red
flags or give me the egg that aren't
that
they don't know what's a red flag what's
it not they just all equate it to oh red
flag depends on what they hold their
value on because if you depending on
what
like what you
take as your morals and values and what
you're looking for when you date or if
you're looking for a partner for a fun
time or where your headspace is is going
to depend on if you could even come
across people with those red flags
because a lot of the things i see like
on social media and stuff about the red
flags i'm like there's no way that a man
could even be in my vicinity who's doing
anything like that because i'm not
looking in that space what is the line
between
coming
like
being aware of red flags
versus kind of reaching and like saying
that because a lot of times i'll see
girls call every like what you're saying
they'll call everything a red flag
and it's like they're coming at it from
a place of like men are going to
disappoint me no matter what that's a
victim
i think there's more forgiveness for red
flags if you're fine if you're afraid
not really
oh yeah 100 percent right
as yourself yeah right
you'll look through the fingers and
you'll be like oh yeah that's
is that red flags are red flags but if
you're lying
they're ignored yeah until you've done
something that's worthy of talking about
yeah but it's what it isn't that's the
game play the game play to win in it
i'm gonna take a second and read super
chats um
guys all super chat i actually don't
even know what we're we bought a fourth
camera we're going to use it on saturday
um so yeah yeah yeah
this camera
isn't here today but
um so i don't even know what we're
saving for but i'll think of something i
promise some studio to update let me
know in the chat
um also we are going to turn it on to
members only um i'll do it on the hero
yeah
um
so
the first super chat one second guys is
from brett cormier
hold on loading okay brett cormier the
women say i have a lot of masculine
energy really don't understand what that
means they think it means boss and
independent what about being stoic
self-sacrifice and stoic self-sacrifice
for others the uk economist with around
4.5 percent
of men being swiped on dating apps
shouldn't
an equality movement take place to help
the rest of the matches the men get
matches
zero fallout romance is not realistic
like corn is romance novels back before
victorian days is what started this mess
now romance is a billion dollar industry
richard harrington thanks for the great
content i think cool auntie versus
chesca would be an episode yo
um much love can't wait for ish to get
his camera up and running december zero
eight one is there paint thin thinner in
that blue cup
john green just one
just i don't get the joke
there's a couple blue cups
they're saying someone's drinking
satin what's there talking about you
what's paint thinner i don't get it
are you high yeah is it driving you
loopy i think that's you they talk about
you
um john green just wanted to say i love
this channel keep up the great content
thank you alistair horton here's a
curious question on the man staying home
what if he works from home that's what
that that is i already said that that i
was already picturing my current dynamic
the chubby puerto rican um five dollar
super chat thank you um do917 this is
not the first time of of women-centric
rights it happened in persia
aries
every train urethral tonight
hellenistic roam throughout history it
signaled collapse
oh is that true um fragmented dude
person can men create and uphold sexual
boundaries in dating not relying on
women to do this if so how would it be
beneficial for relationships overall
osmosis reacts pearl looks classy for
the pods and then homeless in her coffee
videos
alistair horton
problem is most modern people are
usually hornier than a tr
trieris sops and don't have the
self-control to deal with it aleister
horton they want equality of outcome not
equality of opportunity james sharp
women want equality when it benefits
them and when
and they don't want it when it doesn't
um monkey you saw pearl you'd be looking
so delicious in that dress
thank you
you went you went to that course
she was talking about how single she was
earlier
i have a goal
brother
shoot her calm down calm down calm down
okay black is panther walt disney and
his fairy tales has done more damage to
humanity than pretty much all dictators
in human history
chris 50 super chat
yeah
stream sponsor okay chris or pearl pass
this to the feminist go to planet typhon
there you will be you will find the
ancient ruins of a temple that has a
strong connection to the force place
grow goo on the seeing stone on top of
the mountain then grosgu may choose his
path the uk economist looking good again
pearl red suits you
and then that's it what did is that a
game what was that
i i don't i didn't understand it
sometimes like i just
i just read it
you know i don't like what
you go to a temple and you get goose all
right temple run maybe sometimes
do you okay so women women often talk
about how they don't want to be
objectified
so then why why do women wear makeup
why do women have only fans
why do women get it i think you have to
give yourself this one first why do you
girls wear makeup
all
right
is bad of me but there's a tribe out
there in africa where men
line up and they apply makeup and they
are allowed to
it's not cheating but like you're
allowed to have an open relationship
that day so you're allowed to make one
other honey that isn't your wife there
yeah
so
i'm gonna find it for you my guy i'm an
institution i'm an instagram it's you
i've actually i think i've seen a video
but the point is that they stand there
and they like to have to grin and like
show their how nice their teeth are
and so cool then what happens is they
might not pull
because
they you know he might just have to go
home be like oh sorry love it's you
again but so my real talk so the thing
is it's it again the cul i hate to to
rabbit on about this but is there is
definitely a cultural aspect of of
female makeup and how it is today in
this in society i think the biggest one
that we can talk about
is how like
you know red lipstick supposed to
symbolize blush and vulva and whatnot
one of these things right so
yeah that's just my a quick little
anecdote on like makeup that is not just
that's why like jordan peterson talks
about that how it signals like right
fruit
yeah yeah
like blush is like because i guess your
cheeks flush during sex and so that's
what that signals and then like same
with the lips being better yeah i don't
what does mascara
that's what i wear the most yeah
it makes your eyes look a certain way
and the thing is if you look at when
when you're this is such a random
example yeah but when you're increasing
domesticity in an animal you're
domesticating an animal yeah it actively
becomes cuter
so again that's another thing there's
like a theory out there like if you're a
baby and a child the reason you look
cute is
oh my god we've got to take care of this
because you're cute and i think that's
an aspect of cuteness and fat like do
you know what i mean like
the eyes
there's a there's an element of like
yeah
yeah like i said beauty cuteness and
like it's like that in your eye
it's just interesting because women well
like those screen like modern women will
scream about oh i don't want to be
objectified but it's like then they'll
be shaking ass on the internet it's like
what did you want dianne
what did you think would happen
no they could have you know
i don't think that should be called
female empowerment no yeah there's
there's there's lines to be drawn that
people seem to be incapable of between
being empowering and then objectifying
yourself and using it as an excuse and
just putting it under another bracket so
what element of it is empowering if we
lived in iran yeah then i'd be like cool
that's empowerment you know i mean you
can't no real talk you can't even dance
on the street like just whatever it is
you don't need to shake nope so in that
extreme
empowerment though
i'm not saying it's empowerment but i've
as in i agree with you i don't think
that shaking your ass in front of like
in a video and sharing it on social
media is particularly empowering i don't
see the point in it at all that's
similar
if i can focus on my body and i get to
do what i want with my body if i were to
flex and post the display yeah my body
my choice nobody would be like oh my god
babe you look so gorgeous but the blue
male empowerment no i'll be a [ __ ]
douchebag that's posted like posing on
that it's just something it's a way to
hide that they're doing it for attention
well you know and it's the weirdest
thing when fat chicks do it because it's
like why are you doing this
it's like it's like they're screaming
like like me for my roles but why
it's like that's like that's like if
that's like if uh that's like
that's like if um
like a skinny dude skinny skinny dude
was like like flexing his muscles like
me from my smile i think that also when
we think about um modern day society and
certain women that
that conduct themselves like that there
is an element of maybe maybe it's down
to immaturity
when they become of an age where they
have maybe a daughter do you really
think they're going to be showing their
daughter
the video of them twerking online
because for me i wouldn't
want to example yeah and i as personally
as a woman i i'm not a mother but as a
woman i don't think that's a respectable
thing to do i wouldn't i would not
conduct myself like that so i would be
more careful about even topics that i
talk about when i'm doing maybe podcast
etc where i'm more slightly more
conservative while making sure that what
i'm speaking about is actually going to
be something but that goes back to what
you said earlier about do women think um
short term or long term women think
short term because they don't think
about a lot of women don't think about
that stuff for in the future like oh
what am i kids are going to think or
what are people at a workplace going to
think if it pops up on
there
yeah they just think oh my body my
choice i can do what i want with it i
want to do this right now i'm going to
do this right now i don't care about the
consequences right now because and
sometimes i think it's coping
like it's like they're not getting the
attention from the men they want so
they're like take off my clothes so i
can get it and that's again it's a
short-term strategy because where they
might get the x amount of likes on insta
and fire fire from everyone else's man
the amount of i've seen guys like sat
next to my brother while he scrolls
through instagram lights that's like
they're not actually looking at the
person like it's just a quick win but
are they actually going to date you in
the long term are they going to wife you
you know what i think about with bbl's
all the time like because girls will get
bbl's right and some girls get like real
opportunities from getting that type of
surgery like they'll get to be
like yeah like they'll get to figure out
like i've heard of girls like make
hundreds of thousands of dollars off of
a bbl like whether it's through
instagram whether it's through tick tock
like like you you hypothetically could
say that but it's like if you're not
changing your eating habits
how you're just gonna gain the weight
back in a weird way and it's going to
look weird
but nobody thinks and then what about
when you're 70 do you think that people
listen that that's a whole lot about
like yeah for me i don't think but then
i'm not a person that based a lot of my
things on aesthetics so
even though i might be aesthetically
pleasing it doesn't mean that i base my
value on aesthetics that's not what i
base my value on is it an advantage for
me yes did i choose for that advantage
no if i wanted to choose a sex as an
advantage maybe i would be more a woman
that would go and think about getting
you know enhancements to my body and
surgery because i feel like that's what
my value is being held on whereas for me
i don't hold my core value on what i
look like i hold it on other things and
yeah that does attribute towards it so
it's based on what people's morals and
values are and what they hold their
value on because girls that
in my opinion women that use
just body objectification
any time instagram could could crash and
nobody's a model anymore so you've got
all these influencers influencing
absolutely nothing that contributes
healthily towards our society and us not
collapsing as a site and then they're
just posting like short term and then
what about when you're 35 and now you're
a baby mom then what are you posting
you're not it's to me it's like you
people are not looking and it's not like
that gets you a husband like what's your
ass pic going to get you it's going to
get you it's going to get you you know
maybe an athlete for the night or like a
rapper you're going to get your back
shots and that's it everybody here
that's how they care about it
currency of validation but no
i think what feminism has done quite
well is to allow women to be very
surplus level thinkers so they don't
really think again we mentioned long
term but don't really think
they don't really understand how these
things affect them so from a man's
perspective
the shaking of your beauty this time of
uh we don't see waffable women we see a
quick nut
so this notion of objectification i
think it also goes back to people's lack
of self-awareness again because
at the true core of everything we do
nothing we do is for ourselves we do it
for other people we we are gregarious by
nature nothing we see is completely
original we've seen it somewhere else so
in terms of this idea of attention
you've seen that behave in a certain
type of way looking at a certain type of
way gone is a certain type of attention
whether you're cognizant of it or not it
happens so a lot of women don't
understand this this level of cognition
because they're very surface level
thinkers and they think everything i do
is for me i don't do it for no man but i
always ask this if you went to a club
every day for a month and got no
attention and you was looking banging
every day
would you be confused like like usually
you walk in and you're batting away
attention and then for a month you're
getting nothing you would be lost well
and then girls will be like oh i dress
up for me do you you don't do you
like what what are you in the club for
like you could just dance at home with
your friends yeah i also say i go out
with my friends i don't i don't when i
go out i don't want boy attention i'm
like cool maybe that particular day but
holistically you know you're going to
get you just want to say no can i ask a
question then
chance so do you not feel that you
contribute towards
the way that females have turned out
thinking so what do you think you could
do in order to check if you if you feel
like you that maybe isn't how you think
society should run or women should act
et cetera don't you think what can you
do to help my opinion is yeah so one
thing that really draws me and i talk to
it about with like my boys all the time
is when you get
you get men who are called like they get
ladies attention and they're about it
and whatnot but then they're bothered by
things like body count and it's like
you go out there and you do your tenure
and then you look you want to you you
just want to conquer you want the
conquest
that is what it is of
goes with like less body count but in my
opinion it's like because that's that it
might be that's there's i'm not saying
that it's that one but that is a double
standard yeah so cool i'm sat here and
i'm saying i don't sleep around so i
feel i mean within my rights to be like
i want
somebody that doesn't do that so
do you not think guys that sleep around
can request like they should be able to
ask for a girl that doesn't it pisses me
off really why because it's just very
interesting because i think i think if a
guy builds himself up to be a certain
level like he can ask for whatever he
wants with the similar rhetoric that i
don't like is that cool if you're a high
value man you deserve to cheat i don't
believe in that mm-hmm i wholeheartedly
don't believe it i don't think i don't
think it's like you deserve but it's you
can you can but that doesn't mean you
should be right but i'm saying but i'm
saying
but but i'm saying like okay do i feel
bad for
nba athlete wives that get cheated on no
because you knew what you're signing up
for yeah and so it's like if you build
yourself up to be a certain level as a
guy like you get certain privileges yeah
it's not really on us to like say is it
right or is it wrong it's
it's just what it is and reason why is
slightly problematic is because again
when you're looking at men and women we
obviously understand that the foundation
that we're both different yeah so women
are born of value whilst men have to
create their value so if women have
always been awarded a seat at the table
or someone have to earn their seat at
the table you can't then turn around and
say well you should
control or you shouldn't sleep with many
people because you know you should just
no but again physiologically this is
look we were talking about gender roles
earlier we're talking now we're talking
about i don't know sexual dynamics if
you like yeah for a lack of a better
term and of course there are gender
differences like might i say this time
and time again you don't use the word
virility to describe a woman
am i lying what's for really exactly
really is a term you use for men and how
i don't know what that is
so we tend to use fertility for women
yeah we tend to
and virility is actually the term we use
for men it's even a biological term if
you look it up it talks about one man's
ability
to reproduce to have and look if i hate
people hate it when you talk about it
about like
uh mammals and that yeah but we are
mammals like i've seen people on it like
we're not animals i'm spiritual it's
like cool you have your horoscopes and
that by the end of the day we've got a
heart attack if you believe that men are
animals don't you think that you can't
really undo their biology to spread
their seed because if you go to if you
go to 8 000 years ago 17 men pre
reproduced for um or 17 women reproduced
for one man
but cool so but yeah there's a point in
history that pretty unanimously that
we've said so we started with like uh
uh polygamy uh
generally speaking yeah so cool then we
we it's it's like pretty much agreed
upon in social sciences and we're
talking about single parent households
that two people raising one kid is
better there's even this thing like the
boy crisis if you're like if you grow up
without a father your telomeres are
shorter
than if you grew up with two parents 40
percent more than for a boy so obviously
there is like an element of
communal raising
science in nuclear homes as well because
polygamy also means that less men get
opportunities to 100 women which means
that those men can come together and
revolt so but not every man again what
you were saying not every man had that
cool so to take it back to the mammalian
kingdom yeah no you'd have again people
talk about alpha all the time
so you would have a dominant male that
has a so-called harem of women you're
females and that's how it has been so
what i'm saying is when we say not let's
not fight about like can we not fight a
biology like if i see like a man that
can't control himself and wants to
grape someone and then be like what can
you not control your biology i'll be
looked at i still hold him
okay i i agree that like people have
choices right and it's the same thing
with women like we're high pergamus does
that mean you should just leave your
family and the second
a better guy is interested like i'm with
you there but i just i'm not gonna
judge a dude that's worked for like 30
40 years to get to a certain place and
that's what he chooses to do
i don't think it's like so i yeah i'm a
bummy man i can't cheat whereas if i if
i'm a high value man then i can cheat
that that if that's the way i'm not
saying that's what you're saying but if
that's what people think i disagree with
them if if you are able to get sex as a
man go out there and do your thing yeah
i'm saying my thing is this i also
advocate for sexual discipline you know
everybody wants to talk about as well as
a man i just think in the tabitha site
we live in to be fully monogamous a man
has to practice discipline so me
personally i took a year out of sex to
learn sexual discipline because i
believe it's important to create a
relationship that's healthy and and has
a certain dynamic but if i want to go
out there and throw my schlong around
i've earned it i've worked hard to
become a man that's able to do those
things first i shouldn't have to i want
to i shouldn't have again not every
man's like that so we we kind of we've
like made a monolith out of men and be
like men are ready all the time they
always want to [ __ ] they always want
they're always chasing skirts but the
reality is not every man is genuinely
like that like myself personally like i
had no problem waiting later on
when they say that they're talking about
mating strategies so like if you let a
guy's mating strategy like go rampant
they're saying like he wants to screw as
many girls as possible by and large
and women if they let their mating
strategy go go ramp and it gets the best
genes from the best guy they can
yeah so that's what they're saying i
don't think they're saying that every
guy is the same i just think by and
large like
men want to screw
yeah
i'm not disagreeing with that but i'm
saying again just to add a little bit of
nuance there not ever i know quite quite
a few people that's not what they want
yeah okay so if you were if you were
let's take tiger woods if you're in
tiger woods shoes
and he gets off the bus to a bunch of
brazilian models that are ready to screw
him you're not walking in my willy on my
shoulder yeah
i hear that i hear that all of you right
now killing me bad about a swing about a
swing yeah
so but even even you could say like
that's not what you're on but
like you really think you're turning
that down it's not even not because
again you know that man had a whole
facebook group that you know that man
had a whole facebook group with like
girls that like slept with again but we
okay let's talk about post like clarity
then so you're telling me that if you
love someone and because i've heard a
man and i agree with it like not that
i'm wired like this but i believe that
you could love someone truly and [ __ ] up
and sleep with somebody else and be hard
but i still
i'm happy you do yeah of course but the
point is is that are you telling me that
after they've done their thing and this
bio biological urge has taken its place
that they don't after they've busted it
they're like yo
what have i like yeah of course cool so
not and i thought i should go church
after this is what i'm saying though
about so it's like
seriously i i was repetitious what is
your point i'm getting literally about
sorry so my point is is that cool like
you're talking about this thing that
you've you've achieved and that you can
do and that time it makes you feel good
but after you said cool there's times
when i feel like i've got to go church
so isn't that also instagram but that's
the thing that's for an hour and then
after that hour i'm back on it again
long did postnaught clarity don't last
weeks no i don't like you or not i know
you don't last weeks but my point is so
do you question that
no but
i don't question it because again it's
for me and the most part it's just who
do you have sisters i've got two younger
sisters two younger sisters
how would you feel if they were with a
so-called higher value man and they were
out there doing their thing i'd have
them what they were the man was the man
but that's the thing i teach my sisters
to understand how men are cool so if
they want a high value man
then there's certain things she's gonna
have to expect
i swear to god i've told my sister this
if you was with a good guy a guy that i
judged as a good guy yeah irrespective
of where he stepped out yeah i wouldn't
tell her to leave him i said steven
you're not gonna find better that's the
reality is that because you don't see it
sorry let me cut you there
because you just said you she's not
gonna fight better is that because you
don't see your sisters as a high as high
value don't take that as a personal
thing about your sisters it's just how
you articulate it it's not this is not
so what about if your sister's high
value then does that mean there's what's
the highest woman so what's a high value
man
oh don't do that well there's no way i
could actually i could pull it i could
tell you the high value man like pillar
i kind of do know it i'm just asking it
just because he bounced it back
like essentially like because a high
value woman has to be picked you can't
be a high value woman unless you're
picked by a high value man
that that makes sense yeah so there's no
such thing
as the whole independent boss is a total
fabrication well it's because it's not
what men want men don't care about your
money so that's nothing
and and even even a beautiful one of the
most beautiful women in the world if
she's single at 35 like you can't say
she's a high value woman so you can be
your boss yeah she's gone past that yeah
so you could you could say you know she
had a lot of options in her 20s but
nobody's going to look back and say like
that was a high value woman and i judge
but the caliber of women they can get
while some women are judged by the
caliber women man they can keep so if
you can't keep the man you essentially
don't have that what is your value
because
if you break it down to the fundamentals
of what we do on this earth is to
procreate so if you can't find a man
that's willing to to die for you and
hold you down like what have you
accomplished especially for most women
that is what you look you look to have a
family and i add to that just on a
random little tangent like we're talking
about modern women and whatnot and
expectations and what people want in
life yeah mm-hmm so
but i'm sure enemies indian yeah so like
on my dad's side especially they're
quite they're quite traditional so my
auntie she would have been married at 18
and
married at 17 i'm sure had kids at 18
had a bucket of kids has uh grandkids
great grandkids
she was the typical like the proper like
old school
stay at home mom take care of the kids
all of that and a lot of women would
look like modern wood day women would
look at that and be like i would never
i'd never want to do that that's not
what i'm on but
if you look at her now and fair enough
she's in her old age she's the matriarch
of her family and she commands so much
respect yeah
real talk and it's like why as as
someone's on the outside looking in when
i see someone focusing on their career
which again is also limited and i see
some like that i'm like
i again it's personal preference but i
don't understand why you wouldn't want
that like it doesn't mean that you don't
want you don't want the matrix to be the
matriarch it might just mean that you're
you also want other things in life
that's where the thing about female
equality and what do we actually want
what do we have access to and therefore
we have more choice now to actually
choose our life paths and outcomes
whereas traditionally if you look years
ago because we didn't have access to the
same maybe level of education or the
same roles therefore we didn't have the
options to say we wanted to go and do
this and run a business at xyz so it
doesn't necessarily mean that you don't
also want to be the matriarch of the
family no no cool but women want both
but do you think that you can't have it
you can't have everything so do you
think that some at some point people are
sold a lie it's like you know what you
can sleep around as long as you want
there's no
biological biological clock and you do
it
but that's what i'm saying cool so
that's kind of what i'm saying is that
if
yeah that is literally what i'm saying
is that it's just the difference now
like
we have that you have that ability now
not everybody wants to be the matriarch
but this whole thing as you're focusing
on that career and that's great
like cool let's say you're 30. like i
don't know the biology of it but i'm
pretty sure a lot of your shit's gone
man like you haven't got you're not the
same as like you're 21 22. so rather
this whole i've got time i know i know
of quite a few even my mom's friends
like they're like yeah
they waited too long and they couldn't
do anymore yeah but also what about when
you haven't got sorry but to
what about if it's a case that you
haven't found the one that you're
willing to actually procreate with so
then the other thing that means you're
asking that means you're asking for
higher than you're worth so you're
saying like i'm worth this much and
there's no buyers
so that's that's like that's what that
is it's they're asking for more than
they're worth i think that's an excuse
as well and it's an egregious error on
your part because i think
again and even it's funny because
um in order to maintain a society i
think there needs to be 2.1 kids per
society for that society to live on and
in the west i think in in the uk it's
all it's just about two in the us it's
like 2.5 and in some a lot of asian
countries is actually dwindling in italy
they're looking to die out as a
consequence of people having kids but i
also think people sometimes in certain
societies take procreation too lightly
so look how many baby moms there are
people that are in single parent
households because they didn't actually
think about who they're procreating no
they thought about it oh god do you
think these women don't think about who
they're procreating with understanding
they just they your choice no i'm saying
like they thought about it a lot you
can't they have every option to not
procreate with that person
in the uk you have up to six months to
get an abortion you have time so so what
i'm what i'm saying is no what i'm what
i'm saying is that they have some mating
strategy that they're fulfilling so
they're trying to get the best genes
possible
that's what they're doing they know what
they know what they're doing
it's both
it's interesting but yeah a lot of girls
have been sold a lie um even there's a
book by mcj called the defining decade
and she talks about what people should
do in their 20s because there's this
common misconception that a lot of
people push the responsibilities of
their 20s into their 30s so
relationships being one of them a lot of
people seem to think that you can push a
relationship or you can wait to find the
right guy in your later years but we all
understand that it takes a process to
find the right guy really as we know
when a woman's at her peak is between
the age of like i think it's 18 to 22.
so if you're not finding a man between
those ages and you're still thinking you
can just play around and fall around
which is what feminism and this liberal
way of thinking push you you say pete
what kind of peak are you talking about
peak beauty and peak fertility
oh
is it that short 18 to 22 yeah it's it's
a study
you can watch on netflix where they did
like blind smell tests and they find
what was most attractive for women and
what's most attractive for men
for women it was men with high
testosterone so a lot of the guys that
went gym and
they could smell and those are the guys
the most attracted to you for men it was
women who were younger
yeah they surveyed men between the ages
of 20 and 80 and found that the most
attractive age to them was 23.
wild yeah but i also feel like
maybe it's not just the modern day women
but people are not as emotionally mature
now so that's also the reason and i
think that there's responsibility yeah
and because of things like technology
etc that i think we've come leaps and
bounds but it's catching up to us faster
than we can fathom that can cause issues
with our society going forward in the
right way
it's create this naive thought where a
lot of these things don't matter so then
what i was going to add as well is that
um
even on lbc that cambridge is looking to
teach younger girls about fertility
because it seems that women have
forgotten that you have a biological
clock and when you bring up say ah don't
bring up my clock like this is a reality
and if you're not if you're not thinking
about these things in the years that
matter you have a lot of women who are
upset so that the most um the most
depressed um demographic of of a person
is a woman who's 45 and successful
career woman is 45 and childless because
you realize that later in life
the career doesn't mean nothing to you
like you've been told it meant something
to you you've been told to get your own
and secure your life and don't depend on
a man and be strong and independent and
then when you get all those things
you're like i'm still lonely and the
other thing is that they don't preach
that we can depend on men
like they're always saying like you need
to have a backup plan you need to have a
fallback
and even if you ever notice in the
simpsons
we got the dumb the dad is a dumb they
can't depend on lisa's smart bart's dumb
and you see that dynamic in so many
tv shows where like the dad is just like
a kid basically and they're you're
preaching to women they can't depend on
men family guy same thing yeah that's
the same people i was gonna because we
we obviously we just conversation but we
were asking how do men play a part in
the kind of current market at the minute
and what did they do and i i said to i
answered that cool i'm the exception to
why i'm a bit different but
to just quickly go back on that i do
genuinely think that
it's a bit
we can sit here and be like oh my god
look at all of these promiscuous women
and all of these hoes but it's like how
are they how are they how are they
enabling that because there's guys that
are out there sleeping with them so i'd
be real yeah and i've said this before
women have like a massive responsibility
a massive responsibility
for society by and large like women
don't want to take their responsibility
no more so i i believe that irrespective
of whether our
how men move we move because women allow
it so a man a man can i i can walk
around my wheelies out ready to poke
anyone that walks my way yeah the truth
is if a woman is allowing me inside that
affects the way society works by and
large i think women's true it's a
massive responsibility in their part i
know it's a lot of work but it is your
responsibility because i think society
is predicated on on women and how they
behave as we can see when women become
more free with sex all it does is for
the men who are able to get sex they're
having a great time yeah because there's
only a small demographic of men who are
able to have sex anyway and what women
are doing as they've entered the job
market they decreased that that um
that ability for a specific um
a specific demographic of men to get sex
so now why why am i not trash this time
otherwise because women all sleeping
with the same men how can you have eight
percent of the female population
sleeping 20 of men how does that make
sense what that is literally it's a
small
some argue that it's even smaller is
that because of the high value no it's
it's if you look at dating app data
women only swipe right like five percent
of the time yeah so it's actually a
hundred percent of women want twenty
percent of one but like twenty percent
are too fat to really you know go
forward
yeah and that's one out of three one out
of three men under 30 is a virgin or
hasn't had sex in the past year one out
of three oh my god yeah i thought the
majority of men no about bro i always
say this look at this but think about
when you went to school yeah there was a
certain group of boys
and girls
think about just think about school and
blow it up i thought it changed think
about school and blow up you went to
school there were so many guys that just
did like these guys you probably don't
remember even existed yeah that's the
majority i had a guy on the show that
had an eight girl rotation
eight girl rotation and you know what's
funny i asked girls i asked girls this
question i said would you rather see a
guy that you you know kind of like once
a week or see a guy you really like once
every two weeks or once every three
weeks and most girls will say i'd rather
see the guy i really like once every day
oh yeah yeah no that's why i say modern
women are side chicks
because it's it's a smaller spot and
this is okay so i'll give you i'll give
you an example i always hear that girls
want a guy that's over six foot right
what percent of men is that fifteen
percent yes
and let's say let's say on top of that
they want to be cute right they're not
or not overweight yeah that's that's
like
i think 80 of men are overweight or like
70 60 whatever it is let's just chop it
in let's say 50. half of that you want
to have a cute face half of that you
want them to make money half of that
and it's like we tell girls that they
can get everything in one guy and it's
just not realistic yeah the listening is
redundant that's just that's the thing
or even in just you know like what what
what's sold fifty shades of grey
cause you got this guy that's like super
sweet but also an animal and but like
and bad also really rich and it's funny
the movies that do the best it's always
a really hot guy with an average looking
girl
always
twilight twilight same thing bella bella
whatever she's average looking
he's really good no no it's the same
thing like 50 shades of grey she she's
an average looking girl he's super hot
and it's like you're selling the average
girl this fantasy i swear to god they
know what they're doing no of course
they do yeah what women don't understand
is that it's you that's creating this
dynamic like is you just creating a
problem that you know what's the other
thing is that girls will say oh he's
medium ugly right and i'm like that's
just your level
you can't you can't say he's medium ugly
if that's the guys that are you're
dating that's your level
but that's another thing so like
guys who are that tens will sleep with
girls who are five and you have the
girls who are fives thinking that i'm a
ten now because there's ten sleeps with
me
again it's wrong because the man you
should be dating you overlook he doesn't
exist in your radar but these guys will
sleep with you they will never wife you
okay so what's your advice to get for
women to get
to get these guys that should be your
narrator on their radar what's my best
form to get i'm thinking
you're saying that there's women out
there that aren't that they're not
dating the men that they should be
dating they're not even on their radar
so you as dayton advisor eddie as we
discussed that yeah what would you say
to the ladies at home like cool
how to get these menus
yeah so everything comes down to i keep
saying that i will every single time i
will always speak about self-awareness
your ability to be cognizant yes is is
what destroys most of society something
i think um robert green says that five
percent of the decisions we make are are
conscious for the rest of it is
unconscious habits you read the power of
now it says that the real the reason
negativity exists is a consequence of
people operating from an unconscious
state of mind if we all operate from a
conscious state of mind would live in a
way better place devoid of problem the
problem is we're operating off habit we
see certain things and those things we
come internally we have to know certain
things but those aren't conscious for
half the stuff that we see that's
problematic in relationships about being
toxic about being this about being that
comes from a place of lack of
self-awareness well i always say like
where to look look in your friend zone
that's your level
that's your level
what's your friend zone look like
that's interesting i like this stuff
so it's like but when you tell girls
that they're like oh no i could never
it's interesting because you know
unfortunately i don't have any friends a
lot of the time like
people
want their dream partner their dream
person and they're waiting for them to
come along and during that time they're
not working on themselves too yeah
they're not the dream for anyone yeah
and it's like you're just praying for
someone you're not good enough for that
you're going to self-sabotage when that
moment comes you feel they're too good
for you
every book a girl reads every chick
flick she watches every movie she
watches shows her that you're the prize
for it to be at the table of course
that's the table they get rattled as a
man
or like you're always taught that's how
you treat a woman but they're never
taught how to treat a man
and that's because we don't i think that
we overlook
men in this society in terms of like
what their needs are we overlook that
men are expected we usually don't care
about us
about the new fifa you won and they will
get you a spa trip for two and it's like
that's what you like i've all i wanted
was
a playstation and you're bringing me
that's part
is that from a personal experience
i don't think that women i personally
don't think that a lot of women treat
their man like a king but they're
expected to be treated yeah personally
however you know i think
that also then ends up with when then
men stop treating them and then it just
becomes a whole that's where the toxic
energy starts when no one's doing anyone
right they don't even like themselves
let alone each other and that's where we
come back to self-awareness because if
you don't actually like yourself or love
yourself enough or you're not
open-minded enough to understand
how your brain works how can you then be
going and finding a perfect mate and the
perfect person to procreate within this
that makes absolutely no sense but i
don't think that women
are
treating men right and i do think a lot
of women have become entitled in this
modern day society where they're also
looking at the wrong things in what they
think they want in a man so where are we
talking about the short term maybe
they're looking more at
um
aesthetics where are they taking me on
dinner am i going on a fancy holidays
they're not thinking about are they
going to be a good father do they
respect me how do they talk about me
when i'm not there because here's what
we're not going to do is that there's
some group chat with the lads and
they're talking all the way about how
you throw it down in the bedroom you're
not going to wife that girl are you
because that's that's a thing or a side
chick right yeah so they're not thinking
about
does the man actually respect them as a
woman or are they just going for the
short-term gratification whereas whereas
before i think where women were looking
for because of the what to draw back
what you say about contraceptive where
they were looking for who is going to be
the father of my children my husband and
the head of my household they had to be
more selective in their courting process
because that would inevitably become
yours
fathers are more involved in women's
lives those times so it wasn't just it
wasn't you in your courting process it
was you would go to your family your
family would help you because men in
your house would say listen this is
going to be a good man for you for xyz
reason that that's no longer a thing and
you had to prioritize like other traits
and like the thing is before it would be
like the girl would meet the guy when
she was younger the the dads would vet
them or whatever and she would never
feel like she settled because she never
had those top guys but now the problem
is like these girls at a young age we'll
sleep with these like top guys right and
then they can't keep them and so when
they actually meet their husband they
feel like they settled then the husband
thinks that this girl actually wants to
marry them and is excited to be with
them but she just wants kids because
time's running out
and then they're in 20 of marriages are
sexless meaning they haven't had sex in
like once a month
god 20 20 to 25
and it's funny because whenever i hold
like i'll i'll say i'll say i'll say on
social media like i put
i think you know what did you expect to
happen if you're not sleeping with your
husband now you're maddie cheats like
what did you what did you think was
gonna happen
and then the girls will always have an
excuse they'll be like well did you ask
her why no but i'm like with that she
should be asking herself why she's
cheating as well don't get assisted men
and women cheat at similar rates let's
keep it real but in a lot of these
situations women always seem to think
the grass is greener but you have to
understand you've got to water your
grass for it to
grow so
there's a whole
reshaping of of the women's psychology i
i do also think for men as well because
there's a lot of men who are just mad
feminine but if if a woman goes astray
and cheats or whatever you want to call
it it's she was driven away there must
have been a reason negligence some
emotional kind of [ __ ] whereas if a
man does it he's a dog yeah yeah more so
yeah well that's again that's
probability yeah no but that's the
narrative there's always there's always
an excuse for women i was going to ask
you all 90s babies here pretty much yeah
yeah cool so do you guys remember we're
talking about bundas and that big bums
earlier yeah do you guys remember in
like early naughties when we were
younger that wasn't the beauty standard
that song ass gave an entire generation
of women confidence they never had
before
[Music]
but the wife has the wife standard
changed because we as modern day women
we've evolved over time so what we have
access to and when to draw back to the
equality point is
has the standard of wife changed and has
the standard of man and husband changed
in order for us to go back to a more
traditional society because we because
everything's just so it hasn't changed
and i think that's part partly the
problem so the standard of wife and
husband is still the same but women of
men have changed in terms of yeah so
should we
have adapted our ideology of what um a
nuclear family we're trying to in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] up women picks up like
plain and simple like we're trying to
but it's it's not working it literally
isn't working so do you feel like that's
biology so you can't change social
constructs
and biology can't they don't interchange
that simply don't say it and i think
that's what people don't but people
don't realize that though because they
they look mainly based on society and
what societal norms are in social
contrast and they don't look back to our
raw core as
we're coming to liberal
do you not know about margaret mead and
like sex and temperament
no so it's like this anthropology book
that we we were supposed to read and
it's it's it's like very controversial
because people like anthropologists they
they scrutinize the book and say well we
think you falsified your data but i
think it's still like worth talking
about so this anthropologist called
margaret mead went to papua new guinea
and she con she
conveniently found three different
tribes that had different gender roles
uh
arapasta champooli and the mundogama i
don't know which one so one was
patrilineal one was matrilineal and the
another one was a supposedly more
egalitarian can you explain those yeah
just said so it's like um
the descent so it's not i take my
father's name and then everything is
traced for the father it's all traced
through the mother so there's there's
the
the person who conceived the child and
who's the fart they don't have a concept
of um paternity yeah
so the uncle would then raise the kid so
that's you've got the peter and the
genital figure so the per they don't
have the causality is not the same how
big is this tribe it's quite small
because that papua new guinea is like
got loads of these
so so it's basically a scientist that
like went to find the every exception
that's left on the planet
but what she argues which is again
whether you can scrutinize it but it's
just an interesting thing that she says
she's
her in the one that is matrilineal so
where the women dominate
uh she argues that um
they're the hunters and they're the
providers
so
again from a female anthropologist
saying that i think it's a good
ethnographic example to be like i don't
think it's wrong i just i just think
that again history
the winner always tells the story in
history yeah so
the societies that stand the test of
time are the ones that dominate today
the patriarchy was obviously the thing
that stood the test of time if you look
at nigeria there was tribes of women
that even during the slavery um they
fought off the british yeah that these
were powerful women so again
the patriarchy came to replace it
because that was a better structure for
society to develop and become what it is
today if those things were supposed to
be more prevalent then it would exist in
in troves today but they don't so they
didn't stand a set of time so i can't
say that it didn't exist and they
weren't effective but they clearly
weren't as effective as the patriarchy
because they didn't send it to them
again i don't want to do this contradict
myself and argue for my feels here yeah
but i thought you're going to i'm going
to it's so much disgusting
i don't want you but i am when they when
people speak about patriarch it's like
this abstract thing that's like this
pulling marionette strings in the sky
and that's how i i don't know like i
feel if we if we look at society now we
say it's patrilineal so it goes for the
descent of the man in that yeah i'd
agree with it and the the the concept of
like i don't know the queen is always
used it's like cool she descended it
through her father you because of how
society works when philip married her
um they he didn't their children didn't
inherit his name do you see what i mean
he he just became the queen's
husband he didn't became the king yeah
so like our head of state is a woman
that already her face is on money that
already displays some kind of like but
we're not living in like well that's an
exception and when she goes and when she
goes he's replacing the king
but my point is is that she just the way
that if you look at it the names and how
it's descended it's still patrilinea so
even if there's a woman who's in power
right so it but again this whole if it
was really and truly such a patriarchy
we make it out to be
as bad as people think it is i don't
think we would have that exception no i
i agree with you like that's the one
thing feminists act like women were
oppressed throughout all of history when
it's just not true like you can find
examples throughout history and of women
in power it's it's definitely not the
rule right but
but men built those institutions yes so
how how are we going to go to an
institution that they built and say oh
put us in power when they built it and
they built it based on how their minds
work so you didn't have the same
diversity of thought as well before so
when you look at like if you look at a
panel for example or a pod you need to
have different diversity of thought
right there's no point in having like a
debate or a discussion if we're all the
same person so that's why
it in the corporate field there's all
this talk of oh i need my seat at the
table my voice needs to be heard even if
you look at the medical system you have
health inequalities because you don't
have enough people maybe from different
backgrounds going forward for medical
trials so therefore there's a health
inequality with people who maybe are not
caucasian in the uk because we don't
want to be tested on so that that
creates an inequality because the the
construct's been based on one
sort of you know one pool of individuals
so that's when you're talking what
you're saying i agree it's like
men were in power to create that so
therefore where do we position ourselves
in to fit within
that construct that doesn't actually
matter i think feminism also draws an
extreme so
in order for feminism to survive it
needs to have an enemy and multiple
enemies multiple enemies the patriarchy
when we speak of the patriarchy we're
not talking about the average man the
patriarchy is run by a very very small
fraction of men
a very very few men so when we talk
about it we're not talking about men by
and large talking about small amount of
men the rest of men are just average
does anybody here know who bell hooks is
no no she's like this so my sister
recommended me this book it's about a
feminist uh american feminist and she
it's about her stories are like her
writings on love and why she thinks that
the world is loveless yeah
and i got like four chapters in i was
alright people are reading this like
genuinely thinking like the second
chapter was good i was like cool about
child abuse and that you got a lot
hitting a nail that nail on the head and
there was one thing that she said and it
irked me so much she said she she quoted
an excerpt from another book but she put
it in her own book and she said and this
is why this abstract idea of patriarchy
i'm just like okay
when a child a male in like an infant a
boy first lies to his mother
it's not because he wants to get out of
trouble he's trying to subdue her into
the patriarchy i think that's a
poisonous idea
why i'll have i have it on my phone as a
quote this isn't a feminist book so
i need to i need to read this on that
i'll send it to you
and the other thing they don't talk
about is men had to fight in wars we
didn't have to
and you know you know how the u.s was
started
they literally kidnapped men and sent
them over
and they tried to do it with women
they're like now we can't do this those
are girls and they release them but they
literally kidnapped dudes and said all
right go test the waters most of them
died and then they sent another crew
and it's like oh that's a that's a
patriarchy
they're those ones that are expendable
but women it's like all the all the
the all the privilege we got and
everything we get to do because men
built the world we turn around and say
oh give us more power
and we don't we don't appreciate
everything that men built how privileged
do you have to be to be like i don't
need half of you manny
yeah that's true i think about it stupid
not privileged
it's dumb but even then like you have to
be in a place of i am okay like for you
to say i don't need any man ever
ever that's like like
if we look at everything in this room
some like our phones our mic somehow
somewhere a man has
us as humans
because men run the infrastructure of
scientists i think i agree i'm saying
that people say they don't need a man
that's an extreme feminist view though
not all feminists are that
no honestly
yeah like even normal girls say things
like men are trash better than the
problems
like my sister have one disagreement
with men are trash
conversations and words have power like
they have legitimate power like and
women don't understand how that affects
or even even there's like small subtle
things like he knocked her up yes that
puts it on him and not her it's their
small subtle things that like
progression or even even even i i've
done this before i i saw an interview
from me from a couple of years ago i
cringed okay because this guy i was
interviewing him and he said uh i was
he said this girl like chased him with a
knife or something and my immediate
thought was like what it would you do
instead of but like that's like normal
in society and even even me like as as
red pill as i am like feminist yeah on
some level everyone everyone born after
19 no seriously everyone born after
night roller says this all the time
everyone born after 1960 has been
influenced by feminism you know what you
just said yeah that that that actually
reminds me of when i experienced a fake
pregnancy with my ex and there were
times where i've spoken to women and
they're interrogating me in terms of
like how what did i do to put her in
that state and yeah like so there's so
many things i'm saying like she used
suicide when i was trying to break up
with her and she was like yeah but like
like you must have blah and you and it's
like it's just automated for them to
think i'm the villain like straight away
if i if i'm sharing like my my trauma or
my trials and tribulations in a
relationship the first thing is but you
must have been the villain we let's
let's let's work back to see how you
started or created this narrative and
it's just so crazy because when you said
that i was just like yeah like that's
that's so frustrating yeah no it's the
same thing with like women cheating
when a woman cheats it's always oh
that's what you're saying yeah
yeah but if a man cheats
it's it's he's a dog
or or even even women are expect or men
are expected to deal with women's nature
so like our hormones the way we are in
our period but we're not expected to
deal with men's nature like being
aggressive being being you know corny
all the time
but again it is it really is
accountability because it's like there's
certain behaviors and it's not
acceptable as men we accept behavior
that isn't acceptable but we say you
know what we know how they are or if a
girl cries like guys
i mean that's that's the number one way
i'm in a manipulative manner i just saw
a video of a girl
on social media
she
went on social media and said this cop
like asked me out that's how i got out
of a ticket and they released the body
cam footage and basically she started
crying and saying that like her
boyfriend broke up with her to get out
of the ticket and then as he did this he
gets her out of the ticket and then she
first needs to go on social media and
say he asked her out when he did it i've
had the experience and it's like if a
girl cries she could just manipulate
everybody yeah i've had experiences
where a woman has shot her shot with me
and i've declined her
and then i found out late or that she's
saying that oh yeah samuel was so on me
and i was just oh so and i'm like what
i'm showing dm's like look she's like
she's dying in here like she's dying
she's drowning in here like she's
struggling and it's just so much when i
realized i was soft here is when i went
i swear to god when i saw a girl cry for
the first time and she's the one that
did unto me you know so imagine that's
emotion but that's emotional
this one is
i'm seeing this girl whatever and she's
done something like she's done the mazer
so i'm saying listen
i told you this is i mean that don't run
with me
homegirl started crying at either and
then you go oh did you apologize to
yeah that's emotional um blackmail that
reason
it took another girl to tell me because
it kept happening so she'll do something
she'd cry i'd take her back i'm gonna
tell you but in the girl her friend was
like listen i said the same thing to men
yeah so this game is immediate and
that's when i woke up that's why they
say a girl a girl's only real tears or
when she's by herself
like don't trust these tears you know
what's also crazy a girl can make any
accusation
on of anyone and nobody questions it
like even i've had girls like on the
show and i i look back and i'm like i
should have questioned it more well
they're like oh this happened to me but
i kept hanging out with him after yeah
or like oh he drugged me but i went on a
date with him i'm like yeah
huh like after how on earth and it's
like but because
we feel like women need to be coddled we
can't question them but if it's a dude
like we you keep asking about it so does
that therefore mean we can't be equal
because naturally it's clear that but
there's so many things yeah obviously
one this is not a one-time conversation
but it it there's so many different
nuances to it
do women actually want to be fully equal
in every aspect will men accept us to be
equal it can't
because at the end of the day if i if i
see a girl getting punched there's still
even and i advocate equal rights equal
follows if she hits you you can hit back
but there's still a part of me that if i
saw it would be like oof
it's just it just is someone on the show
a while back was talking about how men
and women will never be equal but it's
more like a yin and yang like you're
going to coexist and evan flow off of
each other but you're never going to be
equal
i was like
i agree with that that you should have
it's more balanced um yeah there should
be more balance with certain things but
because of the way that society's
developed and us all having some
people's super radical views some people
in more western societies and others
the the way that society's developed
with humans is not being equal so if you
look at animal animal kingdom it's much
more stable right so you look at like
okay let's think about lions lionesses
traditionally they go and they hunt and
uh but they're still now for male right
that's a that's continues to go around
so they haven't come out of how their
ecosystem runs effectively whereas
because we've got so much free will and
we're driven by like power and ego and
a whole heap of nonsense we therefore
have developed at a faster rate in some
societies than others so therefore they
can't be equilibrium because we're all
doing things i think men
women are more powerful than men in
today's society by far so in order to
strike equality men need to balance the
equal i want to add to jessica's point
about yin and yang actually just like
in as like a an analogy so it's like
you're looking at it as this perfect
hole but over time you see when you have
the yin and yang there's a little spot
of the opposite color in it that has
grown
in men and women so one and the original
thing has gotten smaller so kind of like
what you're saying
women are becoming more masculine men
are becoming more feminine so it's like
i'm not saying to just undo all of these
years of life because it happened for a
reason to an extent it happened for a
reason but realistically
again
regression isn't necessarily like going
backwards isn't necessarily a regression
you know i mean it's something that's
worked for so long across cultures
i mean
it's almost thought to launch it forward
i almost think like
there's no going back the world's
different not 100 like i think the world
will never be the same after the
development of birth control but i think
just to meet people that you vibe with
on that on that level right when it's
just more difficult what do you what are
you so it's like okay
uh
you identify as like somebody who's like
okay i'm a hardcore red pillar right so
you might then want to be with someone
who
you wouldn't be with a male feminist
would you oh no it's all going to be the
blue pill now but you understand what
i'm trying to say
hold on can i is do you need a red pill
or blue pill as a red pill
uh-huh your partner do you need a red
pill or blue pill
um
listen carefully chad
i would i would i would
i would prefer a guy that's red pill i
would say cool okay there you go that
would be my best slide
you look like you still reflect on it
could could you date a blue pill
you would absolutely be endowed
i mean
i have so i can't say i want it yeah but
you're not now and is that part of the
reason why um
partially yeah sort of um
i mean i wouldn't say like red i'm not
i'm not gonna go into that but
like
i think it's hard because once you see
it you can't unsee it so if i dated a
guy that's blue pill like i would just
red
like
pillow
can't i talk about this [ __ ] all the
time so even if i dated a guy that was
blue pill like he'd be red pill in a
month
i can fix it but no i don't
i don't i don't like guys that are
feminine it's like a very big turn off
to be honest
like i don't especially guys that like
can't make a decision and it's like you
feel like
you're making all the decisions like i
just feel like you're running things
yeah like i i prefer guys that can take
the charge like so does that mean that
you're therefore more submissive than
you like you'd prefer to be in a
submissive role yeah i mean honestly
everything in my life like i've always
been the type like even with my own
business i like almost with my manager
like i hired a boss so even outside of
just relationships i prefer like taking
orders from someone rather than like
okay like i'm just not overly decisive i
don't really like negotiating like i
just rather like listen to someone
okay that's interesting that's very
interesting
chill out chill out chill out
chill out
okay i'm gonna read some super chats and
then i think we're gonna close out the
show so i'm gonna read these then you
guys are gonna give your closing
thoughts so think while i read
okay
blackest uh panther question for the
panel why should a man born of greatness
limit is his genetic bloodline to one
what logical reason is there for a man
to restrict his genes from humanity's
genetic pool
uh child support
mr mr negative if a boy doesn't have a
father at home he will find it on the
streets sexual discipline make better
choices to get better outcomes the savvy
ninja pretty and handsome is privilege
pretty enhancing privilege is a real
thing
one who has privilege cannot act as if
one does not i live with privilege daily
although one should never solely rely on
it december 08 um question for the
ladies why aren't soldiers builders
police officers considered high value
men as opposed to
athletes and rappers um i just say
somebody i mean i would just say supply
and demand it's not a fun thing but
girls i i think girls value social
status really high and that's why
they're considered higher
um hey it's me how do i become a member
i don't see the option anywhere i had i
had just put it in the in an opinion
yeah and a pinned comment
um ricardo mcrae just got into the
channel recently and everything you
speak of is fact can i call you karen
samuels
that's a solid one i love it
a different key name yeah i don't care
chill out
black
panther i'm walt disney and his fairy
tales has done more damage to humanity
than pretty much all the dictators in
human history chris pass this to the
feminists go to the planet oh tython oh
that's the one that's earlier video game
that didn't make sense i'm gonna refresh
this real quick just to make sure i
don't miss any also guys all super chats
are going to studio updates and our
memberships go to support our rent for
next year we're trying to move into a
bigger place so we can stream and like
do different types of content um but we
need to get a bigger place so all
memberships is just a way that we have a
consistent income every month that we
can rely on so they're really important
to building the channel into in to the
new investments okay das token e30 you
can't become unblue pilled overnight
it's a slow process years simps are
still simps dan rich see how the ladies
conduct themselves responsibly in a high
paid job so they can if the price is
right 90 free topay do females get how
crushing it it is to be a man
and you know you aren't seen by women
unless you are someone while they choose
men that mistreat them 90 free topaz
women do not evolve are women no evolve
they are in sunlight now
stefan pierre jerome women underestimate
the power and influence they have women
make bettas they hate and alphas
outgrow them flavor with chef the truth
is that men in the friend zone of a girl
she is not truly his dream girl either
but he she is just the closest
to her
um
death token i'm curious why do women
think they can have a creative player if
women love tall men why is divorce so
high what a conundrum brit cormier pearl
create a tax for the show when a woman
says i think make her pay one dollar you
will be filthy rich in a year every
excuse starts with i think thp network
great to see you back on these youtube
streets thank you good to be back uh
black is panther if you want to be a
matriarch you start building a family in
your early 20s if you are not
prioritizing family then you don't want
to be in a matriarch black has panther
question for the oh that was the genetic
bloodline okay so
um thank you guys for coming if you want
to tell the people where they can find
you and give any final thoughts um now
is your time to do that we start with
eddie
self-awareness i'm going to say again up
your self-awareness up your level of
cognizance and you'll solve a lot of
problems that's why you can find me
instagram who's underscore eddie
underscore um like i said you want to
come on the show drop me a dm girls
feminists if you disagree don't be shy
and look all lovely people look at them
smiling um so yeah come on the show give
me hit me up and then we'll get you on
um my final thoughts
um
i don't know just women just need to
realize what it what is it that they
want in life and
not just spew out things that people
have been saying
for
umpteen years but really like do their
research to figure out what it is that
we have what we don't have and fight for
that stuff um
uh you can find me on instagram at
its.yeah.girlunderscorejess and you can
find me on youtube as well at it's your
girl jess
you see you kept that username huh no
one's giving me a different one so i'm
gonna keep it
yeah the reoccurring theme of
accountability yes
reoccurring theme because it's so
important and um i think also
by what you can afford um purchasing
power so building yourself so you have
like
a higher exchange rate because you know
when when you want to find a partner you
get what you can give you get what you
can match
and um yeah it's all about your
purchasing power and you you work
towards it you can't sit around waiting
for the dream person
and you're not able to match them so
yeah purchasing power um
my
socials is uh
oh g a samuel samuel so
yeah that's me
cool uh final thoughts i think um as
it's already been mentioned making sure
that you know what you're looking for
and what you're trying to achieve so
when you're talking about if you want
equality as a woman what are you trying
to achieve out of that and are you
actually being true to that in every
sense or are you only using that to your
advantage when it suits you in certain
situations um also then yeah looking at
your value as a man or woman and then
making sure that you're actually
matching towards people that have a
similar value with you if you're dating
um and where you can find me on socials
on instagram it's at lola underscore
rose blanc which is b-l-a-n-c so yeah
thanks for having me
um
right
i think where i'm at right now is
i think that both like radical feminism
and radical red pill just leads to
bitterness so like but just one will
lead to a misandry and one will lead to
mis misogyny so we need to come
somewhere in the midpoint take
accountability
start looking at yourself in the mirror
self-awareness and being like okay
i'm not just not we're not just victims
men and women too there's something that
i can do to change that and i think once
we start coming away from that and just
stop blaming everything on one
population we'll actually will get
progress and again
just because something is old school or
traditional doesn't mean that it's
backwards and um if you guys want to
find me on socials my instagram is
moscovaro man
okay guys thank you for coming
all right guys the most important metric
on youtube is the like button so hit the
like button also guys if you've watched
two or more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay that's not
cool i'm so tired of you ninja watchers
like it's ridiculous
while you're at it subscribe to the
channel join our memberships if you want
to be a part of the live chat at some
point guys we are going to take away the
live chat even in the beginning of the
show
and memberships they help us keep the
lights on so sign up for our memberships
we also have a facebook page a twitch
page now and my instagram is just pearly
things hit the like button again on your
way out and we will talk to you next
time